[Música]
les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 arrancamos con la
mirada de artistas chilenos sobre un
momento histórico en su país la
redacción de una nueva constitución
el borrador fue oficialmente entregado
el 4 de julio y el 4 de septiembre los
ciudadanos serán llamados a votar en
apoyo o rechazo del nuevo texto pero
ustedes pueden ya descubrir los dibujos
del proyecto la constitución entre
líneas en el sitio web del instituto
francés de chile cada mes y desde hace
más de un año un ilustrador o una
ilustradora muestran en tres obras todo
lo que le inspira este proceso
constituyente sus sueños sus miedos sus
deseos pero también sus críticas y
además de ver chile a través de los ojos
de sus artistas este proyecto es una
buena manera para descubrir o
redescubrir a ilustradores talentosos
con estilos y universos para todos los
gustos
sentir cómo es que sentimos este nuevo
proceso esta nueva mirada esta nueva
construcción de sociedad de chile
pasamos a argentina a su vecino para
descubrir los vestidores de una de las
salas de espectáculos más importantes
del mundo el teatro colon es también uno
de los pocos teatros fábrica del mundo
porque produce casi todos los elementos
que se utilizan en sus puestas para que
el público pueda ver de cerca esas
escenografías vestuarios pelucas y
elementos de utilería el teatro abrió a
fines de octubre una exhibición de 7500
metros cuadrados se llama colon fábrica
nuestro corresponsal natalio cos hoy nos
da un tour
debajo de la avenida 9 de julio se
encuentran los talleres del majestuoso
teatro colón de buenos aires en ellos se
producen casi todos los elementos
necesarios para las puestas que llegan
al escenario esta pareja no son pelucas
que están terminadas que lo que está
haciendo de ella es el poner el abad
tico en las ballenas se les pone el
número de inventario para después
guardarlas en el depósito que viste allá
los cientos de personas que trabajan en
los talleres del colon tienen una larga
historia de amor con el teatro tengo el
recuerdo de la primero del primer gol
que hice cuando entré en el año 97 que
fue circo de los animales la primera
cosa que hice cuando él está acá fue
cortar plumas para las gallinas desde
que este edificio del teatro se inauguró
en 1908 el público siempre vio de lejos
lo que estaba en el escenario en puestas
como esta
eso hasta octubre de 2021 cuando se
inauguró en el sur de la ciudad colom
fabrica un espacio para experimentar de
cerca la magia del teatro una de las
cosas que más les llama la atención a la
gente primero son los volúmenes las
dimensiones que tiene este espacio y por
ejemplo
el fondo un fondo de tela un pintado
veamos por qué porque uno no se imagina
lo grande que es el escenario del teatro
hasta que uno no está al lado de un
telón es también un espacio con historia
este traje de casi 100 años fue
utilizado para apuestas de ofelia y
romeo y julieta en las primeras
presentaciones del teatro colon a casa
ya llegamos a china la china antigua de
turandot en esos trajes maravillosos si
miramos o incluso hasta el detalle de
los zapatos no como están pintados los
zapatos pensar que en escena las zapatos
me suben los zapatos se fabrican aquí en
los subsuelos del colon el área está a
cargo de blanca villalba que lleva casi
tres décadas en el teatro se luce más en
el ballet pero la ópera también a pesar
de que no se vea muchísimo tiene que
tener muchas condiciones porque por qué
tiene que estar en escena mucho tiempo
tiene que tener un calzado cómodo
entonces bueno lógico no se ve pero se
siente para una ópera importante se
pueden utilizar entre 120 y 130 pares
que llevan entre un mes y mes y medio de
trabajo para las 15 personas del equipo
aunque el depósito tiene más de 20.000
pares a su disposición que pueden ser
reutilizados lo mismo ocurre en
sastrería donde hay un depósito de entre
80 y 90 mil prendas esto por ejemplo
esto es el vestido de durando que usó
callas
esto es un taller de uno de los talleres
de la sastrería
acá se está preparando la producción de
carne de sinfonietta no es fácil ser
parte de los equipos de seno técnica del
colon como éste de sastrería acabo por
estar en un título de lo que quieras
pero si no sabes joselyn hotel diego
oficios no nos sirve o hay que laburar
trabajar producir y bueno y sacar la
producción como el resto de los talleres
las 48 personas del área de sastrería
trabajan a toda velocidad con menos de
un mes para preparar una producción una
vez terminadas las piezas suben al
escenario del teatro y algunas
seguramente llegarán a colom fábrica
para que el público pueda verlas bien de
cerca
a pesar de los 10.000 kilómetros que les
separan argentina y ronda comparten la
jacaranda una flor malva que fascina al
cantautor ya el falla y por eso llamo
así a su nuevo ep malva jacarandá en
estas cinco canciones girl file sigue
explorando temáticas muy personales como
en el tema taxi fono donde cuenta su
historia del niño exiliado en francia
por culpa del genocidio en ruanda y
agradece al poder de la escritura que le
ayudó a ganar confianza
en los estrenos musicales de esta semana
les recomendamos también hay el uma y
kiti del dúo de hermanos colombianos la
guardan pero con cada sencillo los
caleños muestran que les importa mucho
hacer nuevas propuestas visuales y jugar
con los géneros musicales urbanos
así nos despedimos con el poderoso
homenaje que escribió la rapera son para
the great a la música samba rock un
género que mezcla sonidos tradicionales
de zambia con rock psicodélico la
canción se llama never forget gracias
por su confianza y clientes
[Música]
bien